10 in a ray 2 test. Oh, where we are. I had a Syrex array 2 test come back normal. I'm still waiting for a ray 10 test to come back.
A ray 5 test showed positive thyroid peroxanase antibodies. I already know I have line and cool infections. What suggestions do you have?
What next steps to take? Well, I would. So, okay, so if a ray 2 came back normal, that means you don't have enough damage to your gut to show positive.
That's what the array to Syrex array 2 tests for leaky gut in layman's terms. So, permeability issues with the gut.
If that came back normal, that's a really good thing. If it doesn't be that you still can't have food antibody. So, array 10 is what's going to test for that.
If that all comes back normal, then that's a very good thing. Then what came back abnormal with this person in array 5, which is a test for self antibodies, this person showed high thyroid peroxanase antibodies.
What does that mean? Well, you have to look whether that person has either Hashimoto's, most likely, or has hyperthyroidism. That would be based upon their thyroid levels.
If their T3 was really high, then that person has hyperthyroidism, and then we have to deal with that.
That means they have antibodies against the thyroid, so they know that they have an autoimmune thyroid.
So, when a person has self antibodies to whatever, then they have to be aware now that they know that they have an autoimmune condition, they have to be aware of everything else they do.
Because anything that's going to stimulate an immune response is going to make that autoimmune condition worse.
So, most likely, this person has Hashimoto's. I don't know what their levels of their thyroid is, but that would be most common.
So, the next steps are to wait till they get array 10 tests back to know what foods they can or can't eat.
If array 10 test is all negative, then are there any food restrictions with an autoimmune thyroid?
Well, there are, regardless of whether they have antibodies to gluten, this person cannot eat gluten, so there's a side note.
If you have any thyroid issues, whether it be primary hypothyroidism, whether you have hyperthyroid, or whether you have Hashimoto's, or an autoimmune thyroid,
you cannot be eating gluten. Why? Because gliadidism molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So, the presence of gliadid in that person's diet and gliadid, whether they have antibodies or not to gluten, will cause a reaction to the thyroid and will make the thyroid worse.
So, you can't eat gluten. So, even if you don't have antibodies to gluten, even if array 10 comes back all to normal, you can't eat gluten.
If array 10 comes back all to normal, can they eat all the other foods that are on there?
Yeah, they typically don't have problems eating any of those other foods on there.
So, but they have to be aware of other things that could stimulate their immune system.
So, if they're taking because they have live and co-infections, and some practitioner has them on a vitamin C therapy, or a cat's claw, common supplement with live, or, you know, a condition, or a straggler or something like that, those are all no notes because those are all immune stimulants.
And if you have antibodies to self tissue, you can't be taking those immune stimulants on a regular basis.
Yeah, if you feel like you're coming down with a cold or something like that to take them short term, that's acceptable.
But if you're going to take them long term, all you're doing is stimulating your immune response, and you will kill that what you have antibodies against first.
That's the rule of your immune system.
So, if you have self antibodies, and you're going to stimulate the immune response, get what you're going to start killing.
You're going to kill that what you have antibodies against first, in this case, thyroid gland.
So, I have a whole bunch more information on that on our chronic disease and autoimmune course.
If you're interested, if you know that you already have an autoimmune disease, definitely that $50 is worth spending to take that course because I got tons of tons of information on that.